do you try to cast those guys or your
close friends it seems like you do
obviously in in just about everything
you do if you can if it's right yeah for
example in another movie Wanderlust we
had this part of this guy who's a naked
guy running around the this commune
hey looking for the BNB there's another
half mile he can't miss it
thank you thank you
and we auditioned all sorts of different
actors who were great and like different
types and really funny did you audition
them naked some of them did What Would
un asked
solicited they fully make their clothes
off saw their penis it was crazy at the
end of the day as we were trying to
figure out how to who's gonna really
nail this we were just like oh let's
just get Joe and then like Joe Ocho came
in and was like the greatest thing you
know